even though it's been almost 15 years
since the show premiered NCIS still has
a slot on our TV screens every Tuesday
night some faces have come and gone over
the years while others have remained the
same since day one but they all have one
thing in common this was the show that
truly brought them into the spotlight
here's what the cast of NCIS was up to
before they got the roles that changed
their lives Mark Harmon Thomas Mark
Harmon grew up in Burbank California the
youngest of three children two former
Heisman winning football players Tom
Harmon and actress Elise not football
was his early passion but the acting bug
eventually hit Harmon has compiled a
fairly impressive filmography in film
and television
he spent a good deal of the last 13
years as essentially the face of NCIS
anchoring the show's cast as steely eyed
Special Agent leroy gibbs since 2003
Harmon has starred in more than 300
episodes of the series since its
inception
pauley perrette pauley perrette was born
in New Orleans where she dreamed of one
day being a rock star
she also entertained the idea of getting
into law enforcement and went to college
for criminal science I thought I was
gonna be a cop she finally did get the
chance to become a cop of sorts and she
got to entertain millions of NCIS
viewers as Abby Sciuto in the process
Barret was actually introduced into the
NCIS universe during the last two
episodes of jag the Navy focused show
that preceded NCIS Michael Weatherly
born in New York City Michael Weatherly
was a professional actor for over a
decade before landing the role of
Anthony Tony DiNozzo in NCIS
prior to his breakout role Weatherly
built a solid career with a variety of
memorable supporting roles including
dark angel starring Jessica Alba to whom
he was engaged in 2001 Weatherly has
spent the intervening years consistently
acting on NCIS and more recently with a
title role on CBS's bull his
relationship with Alba dissolved in 2003
but six years later
Weatherly married his second wife an
internist named for Jana Jankovic with
whom he has two children
David McCallum born in 1933 in Glasgow
Scotland David McCallum grew up on a
diet of classical music courtesy of his
parents who encouraged him to pursue the
musical arts himself hey you're good of
course at first acting was only a hobby
for McCallum he got a job at an opera
house as an assistant manager performed
vocal work on the radio and finally
broke into films in 1957 he hasn't
stopped since
that's over 60 years in the industry
which may explain why he wears his role
as NCIS is ducky Mallard as easily as a
glove it also doesn't hurt that McCallum
followed around real-life coroner's to
prepare for his role as a medical
examiner on the show Shaun Murray Shaun
Murray started his acting career early
his first break came in the form of a
starring role in the 1993 Disney classic
hocus pocus but since he's long since
lost the vintage 90s locks he definitely
hasn't lost the deadpan charm that made
him a breakout star on NCIS like pauley
perrette he also has a connection to
NCIS predecessor jag although Murray
played an entirely different character
from his NCIS role of Timothy McGee
Brian Dietzen as a younger man Brian
Deason had dreams of Hollywood success
and the 2003 musical comedy from Justin
to Kelly gave Easton the chance to step
onto the big screen
unfortunately from Justin to Kelly is
one of the worst movies ever made but
Dietzen managed to beat the odds and
joined the main cast of NCIS the
following year Ethan has now spent more
than a decade in the role of Jimmy
Palmer and although he's also appeared
in a handful of films NCIS is still his
most successful and long-running gig
rocky Carroll rocky started out acting
on the stage at the Cincinnati school
for Creative and Performing Arts the
first of two dramatic schools Carroll
attended before moving to New York
Carroll remains an actor with great
credibility on Broadway as well as in
the popcorn movie world of Hollywood
with an abiding love of Shakespeare that
he's held since youth his character on
NCIS director Leon Vance has appeared in
all three iterations of the series
including Los Angeles and New Orleans
Lauren Holly raised in New York Lauren
Holly practiced cheerleading and studied
English before getting a start in acting
at the age of 20 she landed breakout
roles on All My Children
ticket fences and dumb and dumber so
where you headed
Aspen mmm California Holly joined the
cast of NCIS in 2005 and became a series
regular until 2008 with additional
appearances in 2012 and 2015
Holly now lives in Toronto with her
three sons and has continued working
steadily since leaving and C is Emily
Wickersham born in 1984 in Kansas
wickershams Midwestern roots play front
and center in her role as Ellie Bishop
on NCIS Wickersham is in her fourth year
with the show as of the making of this
video and it remains her major focus
going forward she took a shot at
blockbuster fame with roles in I am
Number Four and 2012 gone but the mixed
reception for those films probably felt
like a big step backwards compared to
the perpetual success machine that is
the NCIS franchise sasha alexander by
all accounts sasha alexander was born to
be a performer she was acting in school
plays by seventh grade and on the side
she tried out ice-skating singing and
dancing these days she's just about
omnipresent on our TV screens showing up
on a number of wildly successful TV
shows such as Dawson's Creek CSI friends
and shameless in addition to her a
long-running gig on NCIS it's no shock
that this great track record made her a
lock for the 2016 People's Choice Award
for favorite cable TV actress jo spawn
oh now over 70 years old
jo Sano got his start in the business in
1973 with an appearance in George
Lucas's classic American Graffiti but
his main claim to fame was Hill Street
Blues on which he played one of the lead
roles for 144 episodes as FBI Special
Agent Tobias Fornell
sano has been weaving in and out of the
NCIS narrative since the very beginning
appearing whenever the writers deem it
necessary for the FBI to poke around in
the NCIS business
cote de pablo
born maria jose de pablo fernandez cote
de pablo was born in chile and lived
there for ten years before moving to
Miami she was hosting her own talk show
by age 15 which should probably make
most of us a little sad when you think
about the difficulty nature's way of
passing the time good news guys I spent
all the money yes I can it's all-terrain
dummy the actress left her role on NCIS
in 2013 for unknown reasons and snagged
roles in a couple of film including the
33 a dramatized recreation of a Chilean
mining disaster for now the world is
full of project for her choosing so
there's no telling where she'll go next
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]